porter un nom juif même si votre père
est juif et votre mère l'est pas en tant
que juif chante en portant un patronyme
juifs vous retrouvez occident ça nous a
jamais embêté et moi sincèrement ce de
l'aider sa durée de trois ans je n'ai
jamais ressenti le moindre sentiment de
ce genre dans un moment politique est
d'ailleurs aucun des membres des
associations d'étudiants qui ont fait de
la politique par la suite ne sait par
exemple retrouver au front national vous
avez cité des noms tout à l'heure il y
en a d'autres
ils sont tous dans des formations
politiques de la droite républicaine
aucun est allé au front national et moi
je n'ai jamais à cette époque ressenti
le moindre racisme
d'abord c'était pas du tout le sujet à
l'époque c'était effectivement le
communisme la guerre du vietnam les
événements mai 68 on n'était pas du tout
le sujet et je n'ai jamais ressenti cela
d'ailleurs s'il avait ressenti
évidemment j'aurais pas pu y rester
non non c'est pas ça c'était pas ça du
tout l'occident c'est vraiment un
mouvement d'étudiants qui se défendait
dans un univers propre à sable ok